many people have a soft spot for this
breed of dog their coats are white with
black around markings ideally these
should be distributed evenly Dalmatians
are renowned for their lovable and
playful nature merino radevich lives in
the Dalmatian region of Croatia and he
wanted to own one ever since he was a
boy Dalmatians are now rare on the
Dalmatian coast that's why I want to go
in this kind of dog because it's
something special
I found a breeder online who was pleased
for her dog to go to me in Dalmatia
although she had a lot of enquiries from
abroad
the dogs Oh their spots too a special
Jean dalmatian puppies are born with
plain white coats and developed their
black or brown markings around ten days
later marina radevich spends a lot of
time with his dog saw by the coast
Dalmatians have lively temperaments and
need a lot of exercise up to four hours
a day
oh yes another one I'm very happy with
it
I'd never swap him for another braid
he's brought so much satisfaction and
joy into my life in the town of South
drugs some 90 kilometers north of
Dubrovnik
Anita Stephanie and her Dalmatians are
about to visit an old Franciscan
monastery a painting here dating back to
1710 shows a scene with Dalmatians the
Croatians see this as important proof
that the dog comes from this region
they will bread in Dalmatia primarily in
the Dubrovnik region the inhabitants
were seafarers and traders who
successfully exported Dalmatians all
over the world to India for example
because the dogs were so versatile they
were often presented as gifts to thanks
to their beauty and elegance
they reached Northern Europe Island and
France and England they were bred for
many years and were used as carriage
dogs or to flush out gained celebrities
like the Beatles liked to be seen with
them in New York they escorted
firefighters on their calls and became
the services mascot in 1961 Disney's
animated version of the novel 101
Dalmatians thrust the breed into the
limelight in 1996 Hollywood brought out
a remake back in saw a strug Anita
Stephanie is treating her dogs to an
excursion in a paddle boat while three
year old Chaplin is happy to sniff the
sea breeze one year old Zorro prefers to
swim to the beach
Dalmatians love water
they're definitely more athletic than I
am it's hard to keep up with them the
dogs will do anything that's fun Anita's
dogs were bred by joka and be fired
Dragic their kennel is located in the
countryside near Zagreb and they sell
some of their dogs abroad an even
pigmentation and a good pedigree are
important things they look out for if
you buy a Dalmatian it's
around-the-clock job Dalmatians are keen
to learn doesn't take long to teach them
the basics shoka helper Dragic has
already won lots of awards for her
animals a pedigree dog from her kennel
will set you back around 1,000 euros
this is the dog sofa in our house they
have their own place to sleep and aren't
allowed onto our bed but we do live
together like a family
this family also got their dogs from
Angelica and me child
Ava Medici and her husband have two
small children so they were looking for
dogs that were sociable and could fit
into family life they're great family
dogs as you can see they're great with
children they're quite active
they're called active families but also
they're very gentle and they know how to
behave with children I like tell nations
because they come from Croatia the dogs
can go for a run in the woods near their
home for this family Dalmatians mean one
thing pure unbridled happiness